طائرة حربية صينية
تخترق الأجواء التايوانية!!
نعم الصين تريد تايوان
وهذا هو التوقيت المناسب ..
فماهوا موقف أمريكا؟
هل ستضحي بتايوان أم بأوكرانيا؟
أمريكا عاجزة؟!! ..
لا لا بل مصدومة من الأحداث المتسارعة.
أمريكا متعودة
على خوض حربين في وقت واحد ..
ولكن هنا يختلف الأعداء،،
إنهم الأعداء المتحالفين
روسيا والصين وعلى رأسهم المجنون!!
امممممم عفوا أقصد الزعيم الكوري كيم ...
الأحداث تتسارع وأمريكا لاتعلم أين تضع نفسها ..
أمريكا التي قتلت مليون عراقي!! ..
أمريكا التي راح ضحية قنبلتها النووية
في هيروشيما ونغازاكي أكثر من
٤٠٠ألف ياباني!..،
أمريكا التي تهابها الكثير من الدول العربية
وتدفع لها مقابل الحماية ..
لقد بدأت هذه الدول العربية بمراجعة حساباتها
بعد أن رأت موقف الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
مع أوكرانيا...
الصين تقود أمريكا إلى حرب عالمية ثالثة،
ما لذي يريده أصحاب العيون الضيقة؟
(الصين تقول لن يكون استقلال تايوان
إلا طريقا مسدودا ولا ينبغي لأحد أن يفهم ذلك
أو يحكم عليه بشكل خاطئ)
الصين تتحالف مع روسيا  ضد أمريكا
وحلف الناتو وأوكرانيا وتايوان،
كان هذا هو ما يحير العالم فيسأل،
متى ستلعب الصين بورقتها الأخيرة
في هذه الحرب لتكون هي الورقة الرابحة لروسيا
في أزمتها؟
الوضع متوتر ولا ينقصه إلا إعلان الصين للحرب،
لكن ماذا عن أمريكا؟
هل تترك حليفتها تايوان لتلقى مصيرها؟
سابقا كان هناك صمت طويل من رئيس الصين،
لكن الذي حدث بعد الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا،
غير المعادلة وربما سيغير قواعد اللعبة أيضا
في العالم، ونعود لقانون الغاب،
القوي يأكل الضعيف.....
بعد أن غزت روسيا جارتها أوكرانيا،
أرسلت الصين مقاتلات جوية
لتخترق المجال الجوي لتايوان حليفة أمريكا..
فهل أصيبت أمريكا بالجبن والوهن
بعد غزو أوكرانيا؟،،،
قامت 150 طائرة حربية صينية
بخرق الأجواء التايوانية نهاية العام الماضي٠
تحرّك رفع من حدّة التوتر بين البلدين،
وعلّقت عليه رئيسة وزراء تايوان
سو تسينج تشانج بأنّ الصين
"تبني بشكل يائس قوتها العسكرية
وتزعزع السلام الإقليمي
لكن يبدو بأن الوضع تغير اليوم بعد غزو أوكرانيا...
فلا أحد يرد على اختراق آخر للمقاتلات الصينية
للأجواء التايوانية...
فهل صارت تايوان في عزلة دولية،
وهل تترك أمريكا حلفاءها يُلتهمون من قبل الآخرين؟
رئيس أركان القوات الجوية الأمريكية،
الجنرال تشارلز براون جونيور، يقول:
الصين طوَّرت "أكبر قوات طيران في المحيط الهادئ
تحت أنوفنا" وستكسر التفوّق الجوي الأمريكي
بحلول 2035...
المتحدثة الرسمية باسم الصين
خرجت بتصريحات صادمة
للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
عن رفض الصين وصف أزمة أوكرانيا بأنه غزو روسي
وقالت:::
(الكلمة التي تستخدم في الإعلام الغربي هي الغزو،
وأنتم تعلمون سبب هذا،
وعلى سبيل المثال ما هي الكلمة التي استخدمها
الإعلام الغربي أثناء الإجراءات العسكرية الأمريكية
ضد العراق وأفغانستان)
(هل استخدم الإعلام الغربي كلمة غزو
أو عدوان لوصف عملياتكم العسكرية؟
التي لا تستند على أي أساس قانوني
وبدون إذن الأمم المتحدة؟
وبسببها جرح وقتل العديد من المدنيين الأبرياء؟
، خلال عمليات أمريكية غير مصرح بها
من الأمم المتحدة؟،
يمكننا العودة للتاريخ لنرى ما هو وصفكم
لعملياتكم العسكرية؟ غزو أم ماذا قلتم؟
المتحدثة أكملت حديثها بأن تايوان
جزء من التاريخ الصيني ولن يستطيع أحد
تغيير هذه الحقيقة،...
الصين ترفض أي عقوبات غربية على روسيا
وتعتبر أزمتها مع أوكرانيا شأن داخلي،،
كما هو الأمر بالنسبة لتايوان
فهي أرض صينية ولا يحق لأحد التدخل بشأنهم الداخلي..
كل هذا وسط أنباء عن تحرك الأسطول الصيني
البحري استعدادا لغزو تايوان وإعادة ضمها
لأراضي الصين العظيمة،..
(تخاطر روسي صيني)
الصينيون يقولون:
تايوان ليست دولة وانما جزأ من الصين
وكما يروج الإعلام الصيني أنه كان هناك
حرب أهلية وهرب أحد الأطراف الخاسرة لتايوان
وهناك أسس دولة مستقلة،
ولولا الحرب لما كان هناك دولة تسمى تايوان،
وكل هذا بعد ١٩٤٩،
ولكن قبلها كانت الجزيرة أرض صينية،
وبما أنا الصين لعبت ورقتها الأولى
بعدم الاعتراف بتايوان كدولة،
فهل ترمي بورقتها الثانية
على غرار العمليات العسكرية الروسية في أوكرانيا،
وتغزو تايوان؟
عادت متحدثة الصين مرة أخرى لتقول
(أولا أود أن أقول أنه عندما يتعلق الأمر
بكيفية احترام السيادة الوطنية
والسلام الإقليمي قد لا يكون لدى أمريكا المؤهلات
لإخبار الصين بما يجب أن تفعله)
وذكرت تعرض سفارتها في يوغسلافيا لهجوم بطائرة
قبل أكثر من ٢٠ عام قتل فيها ٢ من الصين وأصيب آخرون
لذلك فلا يجب على أمريكا أن تتحدث عن السيادة
بعد ذلك الحادث...
المتحدثة أضافت
(الصين هي الدولة الوحيدة التي لديها عضوية دائمة
في مجلس الأمن ولم تعتدي أبدا،
لهذا السبب الصين تتمسك بالمبادئ
والقواعد الأساسية لميثاق الأمم المتحدة
التي تحكم العلاقات الدولية، مثل الحفاظ على السيادة
وسلامة الأرض، والتمسك بالعدالة الدولية عكس أمريكا، )
(ففي غضون ٢٥٠ عام هناك فقط ٢٠ عام
لم تعتدي أمريكا على دولة خارجية )
فهل هذا مقدمة لغزو الجيش الصيني لتايوان؟
(تنبؤ ترامب)
في مداخلة تلفزيونية تحدث الرئيس الأمريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب..
استمعوا لما قال!!
(كنت أعلم أن بوتين يريد أوكرانيا دائما،
كنت أتحدث معه عن ذلك،
قلت لا يمكنك فعل ذلك،
أنت لن تفعل ذلك، لكن يمكنني أن أرى أنه
يريد ذلك، كنت أسأله دائما ونتحدث كثيرا،
أعتقد أنه لا أحد يعرف بوتين بشكل أفضل مني،
بسبب المحادثات الكثيرة بيننا، لذلك كنت أعرفه جيدا
وأعرف رئيس الصين، )
(بالمناسبة الصين هي القادمة، سؤال لترامب،
هل تعتقد أن الصين ستعلن الحرب على على تايوان؟
نعم هذا مؤكد، لكن إذا كنت رئيسا
لن يستطيعوا ذلك، ..
سؤال آخر: لكنك تعتقد أن الصين ستحاول
مع وجود بايدن في الحكم؟
بالتأكيد كانوا ينتظرون نهاية الأولمبياد الآن انتهت،
وانظر إلى ساعتك الآن،
الصين تريد ذلك، فهم مثل الأختين التوأم تقريبا،
لأن واحدة تريد تايوان والأخرى